polls in France have just closed the
Emmanuel macron Somme Marsh party are in
a tight race with marine lepen sir
populist far-right National Rally so
let's go straight to Paris n where we
joined that Lisa Lewis she's at the
headquarters of macarons on Marche party
welcome Lisa what are people saying or
wow how are they reacting
well we have results here actually
counting down oh but we already know
actually that national run is coming out
first so we will see their reaction in
just a few seconds just these people
here are still happy about the results
let me just give them to you since
they're twenty three point two percent
for the National Rally the far I party
and twenty one point nine for Alliance
people here have been telling me that
nevertheless even if they came second
which is now the case they would be
happy anyways the first time that the
McLaws parties has been dissipated in
the European elections and also they're
very happy that so many people have
participated in these elections
apparently fifty two percent that's
about ten percent then five years ago
and they say and they say this is a
really good thing because we are
European Barty Europe is part of our DNA
so really happy Nablus so clearly yet
was you hear clearly a good result
therefore the the National Rally how
much of an improvement is this for them
well it's very good result for the
national rally obviously but it's if
this these results these first exit
polls are confirmed then it's below what
they had five years ago they can't say
we came up came out first we and one
these European elections but the
question is obviously what will they do
with it this shouldn't have a large
impact here on a national level
president mccoy is still the president
of france this was a european election
not a national election and on a
European level it remains to be seen if
the far-right National Rally will be
able to form a stable alliance with all
the other far-right movements across
Europe and if they will have enough
force really influenced European matters
and just to be absolutely clear and Lisa
and very briefly we're talking about
exit poll results there yes
absolutely the definite results will
only come out at about twenty twenty
twenty to thirty or eleven o'clock at
night
we'll get to reaction in just a sec Lisa
but talk us through that the rest of the
figures if you have them
well they're different exit polls that
have come out so they put the far-right
a national rally ahead with about twenty
three to twenty four point two points
and next comes the Lerner sauce which is
the Alliance including America President
Marcos party l REM at about twenty to
twenty two point nine until 23 points
and third is the Green Party which is a
huge surprise the Green Party was
supposed to come third or fourth but it
has actually won more than twelve
percent of the world which is quite
astonishing here in France
okay so greens doing well in Germany and
in France at this stage and how are
people are there at Emmanuel macron
apart headquarters how are they reacting
to these results well when the first
exit polls were published just a few
minutes ago they were cheering they were
really happy and the people I talked to
beforehand said well we came second but
we're still happy because we won more
than 20% of the bridge
it's our first according to exit polls
obviously it's our first European
election this means people confirm that
they want us as a government and also
that they're prone européenne in a way
and also very happy about the high
turnout which is estimated to be at
about 52 percent that's 10 percent
higher than only five years ago and they
say this is a really good news for us
because Europe is part of our DNA so
we're really happy about this although
we came second the right wing the
far-right National Rally then doing well
but not as well as they've done before
without 23.2% projection
absolutely the projections say that they
will not reach the result from five
years ago they still came at will
probably come first as they did five
years ago but they were hoping for a
bigger wind to show that people are
really withdrawing their support from
from president Amanda Marc are they have
a program that is not saying we want to
leave the European Union we're going to
leave the Europe but it's very rare
you're a skeptic and actually when
reading it you wonder how they want to
do all these things while staying in the
European Union so they were hoping for
more support for that and to push
through their agenda on a European level
all right at least Louis in Paris for
now thank you so much